want to take photos from the
stratosphere even all you need is a
balloon some gas and this over ours
brief pine that's the credit card sized
chip there so there's a software in
there which decides which is the best
amusement rides context with the Lancer
the point is unalaq's time if I I would
send up just basic trackers for the
camera the key thing then is the images
on the camera yesterday and gets it back
with a pie I can just submit the images
and just thrilled this wait here and
watch them come in it was originally
designed to teach kids about the basics
of computing but its capability and its
cheap cost as little as twenty five
dollars mean enthusiasts around the
world are using them for anything and
everything from a motion tracking sensor
a voice automated copy machine to a
super computer made from Lego even a
cocktail dispensing robot Sony now
produce the majority of these miniature
computers at this plant in the UK
production is up from 204 a week to
40,000 in less than a year the sheer
numbers we've seen I think it's exceeded
everyone's expectations I think we'll be
up to about 64,000 by the summer holiday
this this year I will produce our one
millionth unit by around july vision
but it's not for profit charity the team
are more interested in education than
renumeration a million and a half dollar
grant from google is helping them put
pies in the hands of children this
Raspberry Pi nearly reached space with
this balloon launch its founders are
hoping it will inspire the next
generation of inventors to reach even
greater heights Tom Gibson Bloomberg